whether you like it or not
you're now a superhero
very good i'm just trying to show you no
i'm done i'm shown i did not go to law
school to become a vigilante
[Applause]
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice all right let's do this
who the hell are you
that name better not stick
attorney at law only on disney plus what
is going on everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and today we have
a new clip for she-hulk that shows us
daredevil now at sdcc 2022 which just
passed a couple of weekends ago kevin
feige did confirm that daredevil is
going to be in she-hulk he even
confirmed that we are getting an
18-episode long series for daredevil and
it is indeed charlie cox returning to
play matt murdock slash daredevil and in
this scene we get a really great shot of
his new suit which is yellow and not red
we also see him do a flip over her which
we have seen before but it is always
still so cool to see and she hulk
apparently is going to have a bunch of
different cameos not just the hulk and
not just daredevil but even more and
that might be kind of apparent in this
specific clip as wang seems to be
recruiting her for some type of a new
avengers team we actually see wang visit
her in her office wong visit her and
says our universe is on the edge of a
precipice which basically means it's
sort of on the edge of a cliff and is
about to fall off but what's really
interesting is that in this trailer it
shows she-hulk and wang fighting these
sort of bat-like creatures that really
remind me of the soul suckers from shang
chin the legend of the ten rings and if
we actually take a look this bar that
they're in in this clip seems to kind of
look like the same bar that shang chi
and katie were in a couple of times
throughout the film but specifically at
the end where wang actually goes to get
them the color of the bar seems to be
the same and if you take a look at the
background the pictures almost look like
they could match the pictures in this
shot and the light fixtures seem to look
pretty similar as well so i'm wondering
if there is a shanxi connection here
sima leo did tease that he is involved
in other projects plus wang is involved
in this as well and he's the one who has
recruited katie and chongqi either way
it looks like she hulk is going to be a
very prominent superhero moving forward
and is most likely going to be a part of
the new avengers team along with wang
shang-chi and katie and daredevil so i'm
super pumped for the series and even
more excited knowing that daredevil is
going to be in it and possibly some
other huge cameos as well but let me
know how excited you are for it in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you